if you are a david pakman show member
you might remember that earlier this
week we did a story about how if you
stick take a step back from the federal
poverty line and really think about what
it would mean for a family to be in
poverty in the United States that were
actually close to half of the country in
poverty and I thought that this week for
our classic interview we would go back
to January of 2015 when I interviewed
Zach in Grassi who did a great
documentary on extreme poverty and when
we talk about poverty we're talking
about people in the United States who
don't have enough money for food we're
also talking about people in what is
called extreme poverty living on less
than a dollar a day and that is exactly
what Zach's documentary dealt with it is
still an incredibly important issue not
only in the United States but around the
world so let's go back to my interview
from 2015 with Zach and Grassi take a
look at this I'm joined today by Zach in
Grassi one of the producers filmmakers
of the documentary film living on one
dollar
Zach let's start for people who maybe
aren't familiar with the film I saw it
last week tell our audience a little bit
about what you guys did absolutely so
living on $1 follows our journey as we
live in this rural village in Guatemala
on less than one dollar a day and
although it follows our our own
experience living at that level it also
takes a intimate look at our neighbors
lives specifically three amazing people
Rosa Chino and Anthony so this
originally started out as some viral
YouTube videos and then eventually if I
understand the story correctly you turn
this into more of a full length
documentary what was it that people were
saying what was the reaction to the
short YouTube clips first well so this
was like you said it was never meant to
be a feature-length documentary you know
we at the time where students studying
poverty and kept hearing the statistic
that 1.1 billion people live on less
than one dollar a day and you know
growing up in Seattle Chris grew up in
Connecticut we had no context for what
does that really mean
so while we were going through this
experience in Guatemala we were
uploading these video blogs to YouTube
and we quickly found out that you know
everyone around this world around the
world especially back in the States felt
this same disconnect and I think it's
really you know being able to see
through film into this this you know
very different reality that kind of that
hooks people into it and we actually
like you said had over a million views
on YouTube which inspired us to create
the feature ranked Zone I want to get to
talking a little more specifically about
the difference between kind of what we
might consider developed nation poverty
and what what you guys are talking about
which is people living on a dollar or
less a day might book before we get to
that you know I started watching the
film and the cons it popped up on
Netflix the concept struck me as
interesting and I'll tell you this
because ultimately I thought that it was
really well done in the first five
minutes I started having somewhat of a
negative reaction or I'll say the first
five minutes that you guys were actually
down in Guatemala and I said you know
I'm getting the feeling that these guys
are seeing this sort of like a game of
being transported into this world that
really isn't their world and knowing
that anytime they want they can just fly
back to the United States and I would
say ten minutes later it started getting
very real and and the way that you guys
actually involved yourselves in the
local communities it was very clear from
the film that it was not a sort of kind
of privileged yuppies going on you know
a brief vacation to see how poor people
live a lot of the experiences hit you
guys pretty hard didn't they absolutely
I mean you know I remember this one
morning that we woke up on the dirt
floor and you know we were we're sleep
on the dirt floor as many people in this
community were getting bit by fleas
every night and and I woke up and that
day you know we didn't even have enough
money for food let alone medicine to
treat Chris at the time was go ahead was
suffering from Giardia which you
actually is a parasite you get from the
drinking water there because you're
actually getting the water out of the
out of a pipe out of the side of the
hill and it just hit us so hard that you
know all of our neighbors who work in
this informal economy let on average
make less than a dollar a day have such
a it's such a difficult thing to manage
that small amount of money to not only
pay for your food but for your medicine
for your kids education for all of these
costs that we deal with every day back
in the states but you know they have to
be incredibly innovative to manage that
amount of money to survive and to
replicate that correct me if I'm wrong
you guys to replicate the kind of
uncertainty in terms of you might a ver
Adal or a day over a month but you might
not be getting a dollar every day it
talked to us about how you guys
simulated that right so the statistic is
really misleading actually so that this
dollar a day statistic you know it's
actually an average over a year so it
comes from the fact that most people
work in the informal economy so they
might you know someday they might have
work one week they might not have work
you know people are working as farmers
they're working as day laborers so what
we did is we took our $56 each we're
there for 56 days and we split that into
random numbers between zero and nine and
then we would draw from a hat each day
that number that would be our income for
the day and you know some days we would
draw very low numbers and there's a week
where we're actually living on less than
12 cents a day and what this replicated
was you know that people living in
extreme poverty of very irregular
incomes and like I said before they have
to be very innovative to manage that
amount of money and that's something
that really surprised us and people in
this community were actually using all
these informal tools one of our friends
was using a savings group so he'd get
together with twelve of his friends each
week they would put in ten dollars and
one person would take home that one
hundred and twenty dollars and that $120
that lump sum of money would allow them
to invest in things like a stove I'm a
different things that they use all these
different technique
to manage that's come out of money to to
actually survive and in seeing the film
what you guys did I think a great job of
showing is when you're at this level of
income an extra dollar a day can
represent an increase of a hundred
percent of your income so I think that
that's hard for people in in the kind of
developed world who are not living in
poverty to even wrap their minds around
which is that second dollar can be
life-altering for so many people when it
represents a hundred percent or maybe
even more of their daily income
absolutely and it should be incredibly
empowering for us because if we can
provide people with the opportunity to
raise their income by one dollar each
day so they're making two dollars a day
like you said that's doubling their
income and a lot of times you know we we
think of we think of things in such huge
steps how do we you know move someone
completely out of poverty tomorrow but
the reality is these incremental changes
these small impacts in someone's life
can have it can create huge change in
their life and um you know I think one
of the best examples of this is this
woman named Rosa who is actually one of
the stars of our film and you know in
the sixth grade she had to drop out of
elementary school on because her father
became sick and she had to help provide
for her family but she had this dream of
becoming a nurse and she wouldn't let
that dream go and she ended up starting
a weaving business with a tiny loan of
two hundred dollars from a microfinance
bank which loans directly to people in
extreme poverty I'm specifically
tailored to the needs and with that loan
and this business she was able to put
herself back through school and is
actually on her way to becoming a nurse
and you know this little two hundred
dollar loan that normally we would
totally take for granted two hundred
dollars and too much she was actually
able to double her income and be able to
afford to put herself back through
school and and pursue this dream that
she's had for her life when we think
about to get back to what we were
talking about a little earlier when we
think about
this level of extreme poverty a dollar
day or so do you get the sense that many
people when they think about poverty
it's the sort of amorphous blob where
developed nation below the federal
poverty line poverty is kind of bunched
in with people that are living on a
dollar a day as if they're all sort of
equally poured you do get a sense that
that happens sometimes yeah I think I
know even from my own experience that
happens you know we and the reality is
poverty in every country it has a
different face you know there are
different causes people have access to
different resources don't have access to
different resources and you know it's a
very personal thing I mean even in this
community of Pena Blanca you know each
one of our neighbors faced a very
different challenge just because of the
situation that they were in you know
some people couldn't pay for their kids
to go to school some people might have
had you know became sick and that
created this downwards downward spiral
and like you were saying you know the
the type of pottery we're seeing in
rural Guatemala looks very different
even than the poverty in cities in
Guatemala and then that looks even very
different than poverty we see in the
United States people face very different
challenges you know the biggest being in
in rural Guatemala a lot of people just
don't have access to very very basic
needs like enough food you know a lot of
people were just eating rice and
tortillas every day whereas in the
United States you tend not to see quite
that level of food insecurity a lot of
times people are facing
you know much bigger social issues you
know less access to quality education or
quality work even you know have security
issues with gangs or the neighborhoods
they're living in so these issues that
people are facing are very different and
not to say that of course there isn't
significant food insecurity in the US
but but it's different and and there's
no question that the film does a good
job of kind of pointing that out
last thing in the brief few minutes we
have left here the generosity of the
people that you guys encountered to me
was absolutely
and we're talking like like the subject
of the film is people who are living on
very little money who still went out of
their way seemingly to to feed you guys
and be generous with you guys
absolutely the community in Pena Blanca
was absolutely absolutely incredible and
you know we learned so much from them we
were brought into people's homes they
were so generous with their time and
their energy and we've actually been
back every year since we created the
film we have an update video coming out
about the life of Rosa who I mentioned
earlier before she's incredibly
inspirational which you can check out
our website living on one org and you
know it's a home away from home from us
it's not it's somewhere that we will
always go back to in pretty special
place we've been speaking with Zack and
Rossi as you mentioned the website is
living on one org and the film which I
highly recommend is living on one dollar
Zack thanks so much for coming on today
thanks for having me